so
you can hear me is it on yeah hi
as you said my name is michael this is
my twitter handle
right there and today we'll be talking
about
how to apply basic basic uh
functional programming to and apply to
uis we'll talk a bit about a simple form
of united
unidirectional data flow and how we
could
make our views simpler so
kind of touching about what andre was
talking about earlier but
just focused on the particular
particular views
so the goal for this talk is to try to
make us
to get us to reflect about how we build
our front-end systems maybe give some
inspiration to how we can make it
simpler
in terms of complexity so by thinking of
our
entire application as a function of
state and abstracting the input and
output to the
far edges of our system we can create a
predictable and easy to maintain
application so along the way for this
we'll examine how we can use the most
basic building blocks we have functions
and how we can use composability for
building
more functional style views
and and compose different functions to
more smarter functions
so first so
how did we get to this stage how
do we really need to think about how we
make uis how we make
view programming is it necessary to
re-evaluate this
so in the beginning we had the
traditional server client
relationship it was an easy request
response render
that was it so simple flow what was
rendered on the client was our system
output
if we did an up update even if it's just
a tiny bit
of updates on our page we had to do a
complete refresh
so it had had its drawbacks obviously
but we at least we had a complete static
models
of our page so moving on the web matured
we found
we had a need to do more dynamic updates
we wouldn't want to have
just changing a text in in one paragraph
on our page
and do an entire new page reload with a
new http request a new response a new
render
so we wanted a more dynamic
way of doing this so we started moving
more code
from the server to the client so instead
of sending all
our entire structure in our entire
content on initial load
we do now has ajax requests and
dynamically create our content on the
client side in many cases
so what happens actually is we build up
a massive time dependent state
and a representation of the dom and we
no longer have these complete static
models as we have with
just plain old html so
we can think of our pages and
applications
like multiple pieces of individual code
which in some way
are connected and need to communicate
with each other
so the problem is we often have our
applications and we
don't have a clear direction of how
these messages
go so our pieces of code can send
messages in multiple directions and
further
further our pieces can be tightly
coupled
so in many cases it's impossible to just
look at one piece of code
and imagine what the output will be what
if two pieces share some
sort of data and one of the pieces
changes that data what happens to the
other one so
this is this is a model that needs to be
simplified we need to
be able to reason about our system in a
much clearer way
so we have solved many of these problems
already
just not in a ui context and we can use
a more functional style approach to our
systems
functional programming can allow us to
think about our code
in simpler ways just having two
connection points to our components or
to our
pieces of code its input and its output
so instead of having the
multi-directional
different communications bar by our
pieces this will cause a tree
so or even if our system gets large
enough you can see them as multiple
trees connected
yet again by trees so you can think
about a tree
of trees if you like so
this looks familiar though to our old
ways of of thinking about content just
just like the html pages we had we can
read this code
from top to bottom and
statically in our head mentally reason
about what the output will be
so to achieve this kind of things our
pieces need to show some certain traits
one trait we'll talk about is
referential transparency and purity
so let's just talk about function for a
moment
andrei uh touched upon this as well but
this most
basic form is just the ability to
group a set of expressions
which can be reused in different time
and place in our system
in other words a function is a set of
operations
which takes some information transform
it and gives
an another piece of information's
information as outputs so referential
transparent functions
are a subset of the of functions they
have a specific trait
then in simple words
a function is referentially transparent
f at invocation level
we can swap out the function call with
the result of the invocation
so let's take a for instance to see that
this isn't as advanced that i made it to
sound we can
have a square function which we should
if you pass the number two
it results um the number four so we can
swap out just
our invocation with the number four and
our system would
still behave in the exact same way
expressions such as this one can also be
referential transparent so in javascript
we have built-in operations like add
and that is by nature referential
transparent we're just adding two
numbers together
you don't do any other effects on the
system by just adding those two numbers
together
so we can think of a simple
plus or addition as the result of its
edition
because the operation itself is
referentially transparent
so replacing our expression with the
result it wouldn't change and alter the
behavior of the system at all
in code this would look um much like
you're you're
expected to so we can have a function
square
return returning the number multiplied
by itself
and we can think of two
invocations adding together as just
two times one invocation or we can think
of it as
two times the result of one invocation
or just a resulting object which is
even though it's just a scholar value
this causes of course predictability
because they're deterministic right
so no matter when or where
we invoke our functions the output will
be the exact same thing
given that the input is the same
so that's testability as well our
function and building blocks are
predictable they are testable
just as we can replace expressions of
adding two numbers together
with at the results we can also simplify
series of function indications
or our series of function calls
if you will so multiple
function calls can be thought of as one
function call
or just the last call in our message
queue or message
call stack so we can group a series of
functions in any way or permutation we
want
this helps for for thinking about the
large tree that we had from before
so instead of thinking about it as as a
very grainy
tree we can mentally skip all the
details
and think of our tree as a more much
more simplified three
so again this requires our functions to
follow the same pattern they need
they need to be referential transparent
so with referential transparency we also
can
have composability so
we can derive new functions that are
also referential transparent
we can take two functions with the same
argument list
and the same return type and we can
compose them
into a new derived function
composing can sometimes be denoted as
dots but in javascript
of course it's just a function so a
function taking one or more functions
and returning a function function yet
again so this is called a higher order
function
composability of functions can allow us
to build larger systems larger
applications
by just by adding multiple small pieces
together
and each of those individual pieces are
easy to understand and simple to
understand
so what this buys is the potentiality
to look at one single piece and without
even knowing the rest of the system
just by knowing its input you can see
what it should output
another way to use composability is to
attach a predefined set of arguments to
a function
so this is called partial application
probably heard about this we can derive
a new function
which takes any norm any number of
arguments arbitrary number of arguments
fewer than the original function
function
so we gradually build up our
application one functional one compose
composing at a time
so by having simple building blocks we
can build our application
one step at a time one important feature
functions that are is referential
transparent
as purity so we can't have side effects
between
functions not one code inside
one function can alter the behavior of a
different function
or a different section in your
application except for what it outputs
unless often we can have these kind of
side effects without even knowing it in
our applications
so everyone probably know this
javascript objects are per default
mutable
so this means that two functions f2
functions get past
the same object and that object is
changed in some way
inside one of the functions the other
function has to leave
liv with the consequences of that change
so
this is a fairly common side effect and
often it's fairly common to have this
sort of bugs in larger systems
you can pass in object options
options objects to two sets of plugins
or
two sets of code and one of them changes
the object
and the other one then has to live with
their consequences
so this doesn't all only apply to
objects in a sense it's all values
passed by reference
so this is one way our functions can be
tightly coupled between them
there might be a better way to avoid the
shared mutable states
of objects leaking through our system
instead of passing mutable objects to
our functions to our building blocks we
can use
immutable objects
immutable objects works in a fairly
fairly same way as other objects but
instead of altering the existing object
you would create a new object
when it's changed and you would have to
store a reference to a new object
this means the original object is
unchanged and we can still have a
reference to it
not only will we avoid accidental shared
state
but we will also be able to use and
reuse our old structures in different
ways
as we always create new references and
new objects when we change or swap any
of the value
of immutable data structure
we can easily check if two objects are
the same
there's no need to have deep value
checks or
the only thing we have to do is check if
two references
references point to the same memory slot
if they are their objects are equal
so this is a
very cheap operation reference checks
aren't costly at all in contrast to
value deep value checks which can be
very costly
especially with large structures and
large trees
it might it might sound like immutable
structures
are not very memory efficient but that's
in most cases not not true so we can use
something called
persistent data structure in which
if you change small bits of data
in our larger structure we only swap out
the new data in a particular tree and we
share
the old data between them
by having immutable values this way we
can pass the same object
to different functions and not to worry
about
having accidental shear state not worry
about if the object has changed or not
so the only part we're concerned about
is what the function outputs this is a
simple simple contract
everything we're seeing can be applied
to components as well
so what is a component most of you have
probably seen react
react or any other virtual dom or
library or framework or what have you
can allow us to write
not particularly um you won't write html
templates
but you will write html representations
either using jsx or just plain all
javascript functions and these libraries
have smart ways of updating your dom
they do what they do is they build up an
internal abstract tree of
abstract dom tree and only when the
internal representation has changed the
appropriate update state
steps get taken to output the actual daw
this the html representations are often
called components
a component is as a small piece of view
code
just like html templates elements sorry
and contain one or more elements
themselves but it's in code
so by having our components as a part of
our programming
language we move views into a more
powerful environment
instead of moving javascript into a less
powerful one
html elements are very restricted by
nature
they can only communicate with
themselves and with each other
by using text or numbers as attributes
this is not the case with components
components are much more powerful and
can communicate much clearer
with advanced structures we can pass
objects
and as we know the way javascript works
when you can pass objects you also can
pass lists
you can last pass functions and you can
even pass something like
observables components can have the same
traits
as regular function they can be
referential transparent
and they can be composable
so the same way we can derive a new
function we can also derive a new
component
for instance we can compose two
components creating a new component
which is the combination of the two
we call these we can call them higher
order components
so we can also partially apply
components using higher order components
by partially applying some bit of
information to a component
we can create a component that is much
more semantically clear
and is much more focused and what its
goal is
components can work exactly like
functions
stateless pieces of code which transform
one information one input and result to
another information as an output
of course we can use other functional
patterns of functional building tools
for our components as well we can use
map we can use filter we can use reduce
or even decorators so by having
by applying different functional
patterns we can take very simple
components
deriving components with more more
functionality
just by adding small pieces together
so so a huge huge advantage of this
is that we're still able to use our
components
in different ways in different settings
in different time our
individual components and the new
derived functions
we can output our components to the dom
by using function that takes a component
and a mounting point this can
this can be achieved by using something
like react virtual dom
any any virtual dom implementation
really so
this would diff the output we had with
the actual dom just perform the
observation operations needed with the
dom right
but the important part here is we update
the dom to
reflect our truth our truth in the code
not the dom being the source of the
truth itself
and of course our system is referential
transparent is pure
so we can so we can have unpredictable
output and testable output
we can do rendering multiple times with
the same input
and the system wouldn't actually do any
dom operations
it might seem like we have a problem
here though it seems like we
continuously
communicate with a rather huge side
effect the dom
this will break our system being pure
and referentially transparent
but even if we have immutability and we
take care of having all our functions
pure all our components pure
and referentially transparent we still
have to integrate with the dom
we still have to have some output for
our system
the dom is just a massive blob of states
and a huge mutated side effects allowing
our
functions to be tightly coupled so just
as we saw with actual
accidental shared state between objects
we can have accidental shared state
and tightly coupled through the dom
if all our building blocks can
communicate directly with the dom
directly to the integration point that
is the dom our functions aren't pure
they aren't referentially transparent
even if they may look that way initially
so there's no avoiding the integration
points
but we can do we can move all the
integration points all the
stateful communication to the far edges
of our system
to the far edges of our data data flow
graph
we don't have to worry about the state
leaking through our applications
we can have one top global immutable
structure which which holds
all of our information we can pass the
global structure as input to our top
components and that component
can distribute its state as input to the
different
objects this is also true for
integrating with a dom
remember dom is just the integration
point it's just our
output by having the data fetching
integration in the at the beginning
and let the data flow through our system
to its end output
to the dom this can
uh simplify how we can think about
system and
by directing all the communication from
top to bottom or start to end
we get what is often called a
unidirectional
data flow so remember again
we have referential transparent
components we can think of our
application as a single function call
mentally we can replace the entire tree
with just the top
function call and think of it just as a
function of states
so sometimes we have to do updates
we have to swap out some part of our
application states
after all applications that just render
some outputs
are rather dull so what we do is we send
a message back to the
top state or from any other place
to the dom to the top global structure
and when a value of the immutable
tree has been swapped a new invocation
of our system occurs
so this is think about it it's it's
essentially just the same as doing a
complete browser reload
just we we can go back to our simple
mental model that we have the good old
html
we can read the page from top top to
bottom without having
a massive blob of mutative mutative
state buildup
but by having distinct states over time
stored at the top
abstracted to the far edges so none of
our stateful interaction
is leaking through our system
by sending messages to our global state
we can get
some sort of revision history between
our changes
every time some something in our system
changes we get a new iteration of the
top structure
this means we can step through our
system and
react to error if some error is an
uncaught error occurs
so then we can pop the last state and go
back to the working
version we can even build test tools and
instead of having to click through our
applications
we're using some tedious tools like
selenium to click through
and record a session we could just take
our history
serialize it and step through it through
time
and check our output for each iteration
this is much simpler
to to build robust systems so another
use
would be to do something like
serialization of our top
application state if an error occurs
so by serializing the
entire application states we can log it
to a logging server
and on our local development machine we
can take the entire state
and the same code base the same revision
and reproduce any error that occurred
this makes it really easy to fix some
bugs
initially this render loop we have by
sending data down and updating and doing
a new
loop or a cycle if you will initially
this render loop can seem like it would
be slow but in most cases it actually
works
rather well as we follow of course
the principle of referential
transparency we know that
if the input hasn't changed the output
shouldn't change either
this means we can omit updating a
component that's past
input that's unchanged from the last
iteration of our application state
so this will only update a leaf node or
any of its parents that it has changed
none of the siblings or rest of the
trees rest of the components in the
trees
should update this works really great
with using something like react or any
other
virtual dom implementation which is
very the output as well so we have
double diffs
this of course no um silver bullet as
any library or implementation is so
if you do high frequent updates you
might stress the garbage collector
you might do more memory and cpu time
but for the most cases this works
pretty good so to summarize
we see how we can use patterns from
functional
functional programming to program our
views and this is often thought of as a
poor fit due to the state
stateful nature of ui programming
the dom is just a side effect right so
we can see by thinking our system as a
function of state
where we have the global structure at
the top
and global immutable structure to avoid
sharing mutable states
and using a render loop to achieve a
static mental model
much like we had with the good old html
but this
instead of having static html we have
still the power and the flexibility of
programming
so it's merging the two worlds
all of these ideas can be realized using
react or using any virtual dom
implementation it's just an idea
it's just an inspiration it's just a way
you build your applications by using
thinking thoroughly through how you
build your functions
my hope is and it seems that it might be
heading that way is for react to get
built-in support for stateless functions
uh
as for now it's not that straightforward
you have to use
something called something that looks
like classes
this is why we created a very very small
syntactic sugar on top of react
and a smart logic to check whether or
not the components should update
based on the past input as mutable
structures
and this library encourages these kinds
of patterns we're seeing
so if this talk is was at all
interesting to you
check out the omniscient project and
help on improving on its ideas
or just check out the reading material
or say why you disagree or if you even
disagree
if you're interested in learning more
these are some links you can check out
i didn't get much into how immutable
data structure works
just briefly hand waved over it but you
could you should check out lee byron's
talk from react conf
which goes much more into it and has
great information you should also check
out closurescript library arm
a library which amnesian has built most
of its core ideas from
so thank you
so
again we're on the sofa time and honest
questions
are there any questions there's one
right here
and there's one over there all right uh
very good stuff
so with the global big state approach uh
the benefits are obvious like go global
undo
and state serialization etc etc and that
is assuming that all the ui components
are built with
this specific framework whether it's
omniscient or react
and okay so let's imagine that in the
next two years web components are the
next big thing so if we're using
extensively web components
they own their own state so then your
global big state will not have
everything and you will not get the
benefits that we mentioned so what to do
my argument is that the next big thing
isn't really web components and probably
it is not going to be but you can have
like windows to your applications and
using this arc
this style of architecture and other
parts of your system
doesn't entirely follow that you can
have some parts of your system using it
you're not restricted using one type of
architecture one
type of paradigm in your system but you
use the paradigms to fit
the type of problem you have so i don't
know if that answer your question
there was another question second row
thank you thank you for the talk um i
was asking myself do you believe that
the fact that we have the html tags
inside the javascript like
with jsx is necessary or can we move to
something like
directive.js where the templates are
externalized
yeah so your question is
how i feel about jsx is that pretty much
it or
do you feel it's necessary for the for
this approach no it's not
jsx isn't necessary and often i don't
use it
at all you can just have functions and
that's what jsx really is it's a small
transpire layer to a function call
which is a kind of a hairy syntax but
you can make the syntax clear just like
in cycle it's clear or
it's easier to use but you're
you need to have an internal
representation
of the dom and the ability to to
do smart logic for updating to to be
able to have efficient
render loops so some sort of
representation of html in code
is yeah required but i think that's the
direction that
you might be headed to
include the output to the more
powerful environment that is programming
instead of moving programming into
to the views all right thank you
oh i can see your hand over here and
over there
who's going to be first oh wait conflict
could you please elaborate on the
concept of preferential
transparency it's not
clear to me what referential
transparency is
where which sorry the concept of
referential
transparency okay so the concept of
referential transparency is just the
ability
to swap out the invocation of a function
with a result of the invocation
and that's that wouldn't
in some way alter the behavior of the
rest of the system
so it's just an expression to say that
there's not one code inside the function
that alters the behavior
of your system as a whole if that makes
sense it makes sense thank you
okay so i had a question
when the here yeah
yes sir obviously when you have this
state
like you know one global object uh it
becomes
kind of like uh very big and complex
so what's your solution to structure
the state do you like structure
is it somehow as the element three or
how are you doing that one it won't
necessarily become complex
it would be big not necessarily complex
but you could also
split up your application to sub modules
and sub
parts of your system which have in turn
their
global objects if you will so you can
have a you can have a tree of global
objects as well if your system is large
enough
it depends on how you use it so so you
can
split up the different components as
modules and
and have some parts of your page one
global object
and perhaps a global object on the top
that
stores the global objects so yeah
tree of trees okay thanks okay one more
question
to win the first round um
what are strategies for sharing global
immutable state between a client and a
server
are there strategies for sharing global
immutable state
between the client and the server does
it make sense to do that there are some
initiatives some call bases that try to
patch or do like um scuttlebot
things with the structure on the server
side and
on the client side so yeah there uh
there are a few links on it
on the github page
here uh you mentioned omniscient
which is really modern and fun
technology to me
you are maybe aware of presentation from
martin klotman about
event streams that in your system you
have
lock of immutable facts
um if you know that presentation have
you tried
uh built frontend system like that
that there is only this event stream
yeah
so i've used reactive extensions or
bacon
as well but i usually use it to abstract
like
time-dependent or data-dependent
asynchronous achievements so you can use
still
reactive extensions and event streams to
uh
and it will nicely play with omniscient
yeah as long as you update as long as
you update the global state and
invoke the system and you you can uh
have any integration point you want
right okay thanks
so it seems like uh everyone wants to
fix your pick your brain
but we have another talk so thank you
michael that was amazing thank you
thanks for all the questions so if you
want more questions just cut michael
[Applause]
afterwards